what does it take to design a great
processor so design this system on a
chip that you mentioned is there some
insight you can provide in this chaos of
engineers
designers
leaders
uh you know the people that think about
how much this is all gonna cost all the
whole mess of it i'm of course very
partial about it i've been in this
company for probably more than 26 years
but um
would argue that there are a couple
things that are ingredients for the
success
so we talk about the fact that you have
all those different technologies they
evolve at their own pace and you have to
be good in each one of them and you need
to then to make them working together so
so you need to have an engineering
organization that
with a
incredible collaboration culture because
everybody has to be working the train is
going to leave the station every card
needs to be there right when it leaves
the station it needs to leave on time
especially in the phone business you can
change
christmas you cannot change black friday
you cannot change all of the selling
season so the phones are going to launch
on time and every technology needs to be
there the engineer needs to work as one
and we do have that at qualcomm the
other thing you have to have incredible
uh discipline
because
you know those are very complex systems
so
in one way you have to design with
quality
because in many cases we're going to be
ramping production and even before we
have the silicon back and you have to
rely
on runner simulation models and you have
to rely
on on the fact that you design uh for
commercial applications that takes
that takes a while to build and uh
and you know it's probably been the
history of a semiconductor business at
qualcomm so you mean like the framework
of how many people can use simulation
software and all that kind of stuff to
build the thing with a hard deadline
that you might not even get back from
like manufacture
before
you're not allowed to have any mistakes
no wonder our name is quality
communications oh i never even thought
about the qual part quality it's a
quality and there's a bar that's high
and you're not allowed to mess up i mean
to me as an engineer that's exciting
hard deadlines
no room for mistakes i love it super
stressful but i love it
you